كيف ستكون وصل نعم نعم وصل
نعم
مسار الموكب الموكب الاحمر هو الموكب الذي
يتم فيه يعني من خلاله
يستقله
العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله
دائما ما يخصص للمناسبات الرسميه لاستقبال
الضيوف
للتجوال في منطقه في شوارع عمان قبل ان
يكون هناك مركبات كان هذا
الموكب الاحمر
هذه الصوره للوصول للعريس ولي العهد
الاردني الامير حسين بن عبد الله ستبدا
الان مراسم
زفاف او عقد القران نشاهد الان الملك عبد
الله الثاني ياخذ مكانه الان
قبل دقائق ربما الان
العريس الامير الحسين بن عبد الله ستتم
مراسم عقد القران الان نشاهد والد العروس
في حضور والد العريس الملك عبد الله
الثاني شموع الحضور والمدعوين من رؤساء
وكبار ايضا المسؤولين من دول العربيه
والاسلاميه
الدول العالم
ممن وصفهم الصوره الان
للمحتفه به
الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
يصل الى قصر زهران يتجه حسب المسار والممر
المعادله
في التوجه
الى حيث يستقبله الان والده الملك عبدالله
الثالث
تابع الصوره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات